[Music]
men and women are biologically different
saying this is controversial in 2022
because a part of the country's gone mad
on average men are bigger we're stronger
we have testosterone coursing through
our veins we have a competitive physical
advantage over women courtesy of our
chemical makeup
so it's simply unfair for men and women
to compete against each other
athletically in officially sanctioned
events don't believe me this is mma
fighter alana mclaughlin straight up
pummeling her competition in the octagon
and this is her when she was a man
listen i love sports and i understand
why a transgender woman would want to
compete in them but i also understand
why your competition biological women
would have a problem with that
they're at a disadvantage and it hurts
their chance of winning championships
scholarships meddling at the olympics or
just enjoying the fair spirit of the
game
so what is the solution
at 5 pm today south dakota governor
christie gnome signed a bill to limit
collegiate and k-12 athletes to the sex
given on their birth certificate
the bill's the strongest in the nation
so far for protecting women's sports
this is about fairness this is about
making sure that our girls have a chance
to be successful and to compete to win
scholarships potentially go on and play
professional sports beyond that we want
them to have the opportunity joining me
now governor christie knope all right so
governor if
we decide to move to south dakota
and
i
bring my twin girls who are 10 years old
you're saying
and i might do this for tax purposes
anyway so you're saying that they would
never have to compete against a
biologically born man if that person has
an m
on their birth certificate
it is true that your girls will have a
level playing field they'll get the
chance to compete only against other
biological females as reflected on their
birth certificate because we want them
to have a chance to be successful we
recognize there's a lot of different
competitions such as academic debate
speech that your biological sex isn't
that much of a factor but it is when it
comes to sports and here in south dakota
in our k-12 system and at our college
level we're going to ensure that those
girls have a chance to compete is there
any wiggle room here because there is
some issues with the ncaa and
sponsorships and boycotts is this thing
airtight
it is and what it does is it allows the
girls that didn't make the team because
a biological male made the team it
allows them the chance to go after
litigation for the opportunity to play
it doesn't uh create a trial lawyer's
dream and create a lot of
new litigious opportunities what it does
is it says hey listen i want an
opportunity to play and it gives them a
chance to challenge that school district
to be a part of that team
well i think everybody knows how much i
dislike trial lawyers and how much i
love my daughters and how much i want my
daughters to win
and uh and win in a fair way and i think
that's important we want to compete and
we want to compete fairly so hopefully
uh what you've done there in south
dakota creates a fair and level playing
field and
people should applaud you for that thank
you so much governor
thank you josie appreciate appreciate
you having me on hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else